[Music]
so can I ask you a hypothetical question
oh dear I don't like hypothetical
questions no I don't think you're gonna
like the real one either do you have the
papers not yet this is a devastating
security breach that was leaked out of
the Pentagon the most highly classified
documents of the war the time says 7,000
pages detailing how the White House has
been lying about the Vietnam War for 30
years the way they lied those days have
to be over okay people are concerned
about having a woman in charge of the
paper that she doesn't have the resolve
to make the tough choices
Thank You Arthur for your frankness
let's do our jobs find those pages
you're talking about exposing years of
government secrets
is that legal what is it you think we do
here for a living kid then I might have
something must be precious cargo
it's just government secrets the New
York Times was barred publishing any
more classified documents dealing with
the Vietnam War if you'd publish will be
at the Supreme Court next week
meaning we could all go to prison to
make this decision to risk her fortune
and the company that's been her entire
life
well I think that's brave if the
government wins the Washington Post will
cease to exist and if we don't hold them
accountable who will we can't hold them
accountable for don't have a newspaper
the Nixon will muster the full power of
the presidency and if there's a way to
destroy you by God you'll find it I'm
asking your advice
not your permission she can't do this
the legacy of the company is at stake
what will happen that we don't publish
we will lose the country will lose
what are you going to do mrs. Graham
[Music]
you